um I think probably more romantic right
because you're in love with this person
and then that's a part of who you love
and you like to hold on to trauma and
and you like to hold on to trauma that'd
be so mad as every woman likes to do
[Music]
this woman gives birth late husband's
baby three years after he died of cancer
she saved it wait what she died or he
died he died he's dead three years later
so she saved it you know what it is what
is it the turkey baster yo yo dude I
gotta say it like that is that is that
what you had to explain your mom turkey
baster no no I was that she knows what
turkey baster is
um so she saved she saved the sperm
that's great she saved the sperm that's
pretty tight wait isn't that
non-consensual if he didn't agree that
he wanted a baby with her well I think
if he gave her the sperm to save did he
give it to her right dang you're dark
you're wild dude yeah she just stopped
the condom now
she was the news reporter got it they're
right here
it's in the article
it's like splashing on the lens it's
getting all blurry it's like a mistletoe
yeah for their next boyfriend it's a boy
so yeah this Widow is giving birth to a
daughter three years after the baby's
father died that's kind of really sweet
and cute I think yep yeah it is is it
sweet and cute when you're about to turn
the [__] title oh this is gonna be a
bad thing oh no you guys are just so
dark I'm just I'm just sharing a very
nice sweet and cute story I like it so
far I don't think you can have a baby
three years after with the same guy
because he when he planted you with the
with the sperms oh [__] is that gonna be
an issue feel free to dive deeper into
that explanation because it's only nine
months oh you could only save it for
nine months no no no no no I'm so
confused what's happening yeah what is
happening right now I think in Joe's
mind they had sex he died and then she
held the baby in there for three years
she she was actually in my mind I'm like
she cheated what is happening right now
I'm like she cheated oh [__] because
then it can't be his baby is it cheating
if he died three years before but it is
his baby how do they know that because
of DNA yeah
Lawrence knows his friend I know it I
think she boned somebody else you think
so so he was diagnosed okay just days
after he proposed he was diagnosed with
stage four bowel and liver cancer oh
that's rough before he started treatment
he and his fiancee froze some of his
sperm the two proceeded to get married
uh on May 3rd 2019 the day of his death
what
wow so the wedding was a funeral it was
hard kind of whoa well the wedding was a
wedding and then the funeral was shortly
after a couple weeks after funeral was a
honeymoon really why why would you do it
like that like Get Married the day of
their death haven't you seen A Walk to
Remember yeah bro they did that I don't
think they timed it on perfect like that
right he probably just got so excited
and then she was probably being like
bridezilla and [__] and he's like I
can't take this [__] weddings are
stressful he died he's like take me now
so uh they still managed uh she still
managed to go ahead with the first
embryo transfer and then was able to
fall pregnant immediately that's Ty uh
she gave birth to Matilda
but the thing is there were some
complications uh following the birth of
Matilda she could move things with her
mind
like in the movie oh yeah is that what
it was I forgot yeah she birthed the
witch yes yeah dude she had powers I
forgot I remember
one person yeah dude she's singing that
song in her house and she just she's
closing the blinds the remake's freaking
dope is it yeah that's it what is it on
Netflix keep going Anthony
so uh yeah she she went through an
extremely early labor
uh like very very very early very
dangerous uh despite having steroids and
being put on magnesium drip to slow her
labor Matilda proved to be impatient and
was born
damn it Matilda says yeah with mind
controlling telekinesis yeah she's a
whippersnapper she's a premature Bird
yeah she was taken away but was
breathing on her own for 15 minutes uh
and then was intubated and taken to the
NICU after three weeks There She was
transferred to the Children's Hospital
after developing necrotizing
enterocolitis
it's a severe condition which tissues in
the intestine become inflamed and begin
to die off
Daddy had an intestinal issue and then
now she's got the intestinal issue but
after a month almost a month after birth
doctors operated for four hours to fix
the perforated bowel she spent 17 weeks
and two days in the NICU until she was
finally discharged and is now thriving
happily at home wow what a story I was
nervous they gave her probiotics yeah
give her yakult yup kimchi oh yeah boys
Mr Sanchez
Mr Sanchez probiotics well that's a very
difficult here because oh yeah no idea
man don't [__] matter yeah it makes
it a fun game for the audience yeah they
love it that's so nice so you still
think she bones someone else no because
that's the proof yeah she got his
genetics he got [__] up intestines and
so did she yeah do you feel like
I guess we could only ask Colleen
because none of us would ever go through
pregnancy but in such a hypothetical
that you were at one point happily
married or fiance and then this person
was diagnosed with cancer and had to die
on the day of your wedding
in this hypothetical do you think it
would be more romantic and amazing or
traumatizing to still have a child with
that person's sperm versus like lead a
new life that's a good question
um I think probably more romantic right
because you're in love with this person
and
that's a part of who you love and you
like to hold on to trauma and and you
like to hold on to trauma I'd be so mad
as every woman likes to do I'd be so bad
I'd be I'll be I'll be a ghost I'll be
like how dare you raise this single
child you irresponsible [__] yeah
that's tough that too yeah because then
you're also entering single motherhood
and that kid doesn't have a father
that's true so you wouldn't well part of
me would be like thank you man thank you
for continuing my shitty genetics yeah I
mean because they were they were in love
right they wanted to have that future
and they would have if he wasn't you
know I mean that's what I'm saying
though the gesture is romantic but the
practicality of it is now you're a
single mother and that kid doesn't have
a father for them that goes against all
the rules of P.S I love you
true what happens in PS I love you that
he uh he dies and he forces his wife to
move on spoiler I would never do that
bro he's a cop would never do that he's
a [__] [__] but maybe she'll find
another guy and then you don't think a
single mom can give a child a thriving
life [__] no I don't think a single mom
deserves to give the child driving away
I agree with you
I agree no yeah I was raised by a single
mom
he's like I don't recommend it it's
because of the trauma right no just
kidding yeah but you know everyone got
trauma
travels on that it's hard to determine
trauma who knows bro everyone got trauma
who knows what'll happen right yeah
maybe it's in the will it's like if you
inseminate yourself with my frozen sperm
then you get my life insurance well that
was the plan though maybe not that part
but the hospital Bill's going to be for
her to be pregnant the NICU is not she
guess so because they they froze the
sperm yeah that was the intention all
along well I'm just saying after the
dude dies it's like she can do whatever
she wants but she made the promise yeah
person over word yeah it is romantic if
that's the promise it has time though
too she could have
I think as a dude I wouldn't want
someone else to do that I would feel bad
wait what do you mean like if I was the
guy and I was dying I wouldn't want to
do that I would love it I wouldn't want
really yeah I wouldn't want Elite to be
like hey have my baby after I'm gone but
would you be honored though
what if that that's what she wants it
don't matter I'm gonna pull the plug
kind of guy like I'd like don't waste
any more money trying to like keep me
alive if I'm on Live support like I
would be the same way with like don't
have my baby if it's gonna make it
harder for you like I'm I'm like move on
yeah yeah okay you get get a new life
I want my jeans to go on because I feel
like that's the only way I can
reincarnate yeah is I have to go through
my own genetics
and uh my brother's not gonna have any
kids so that's the only way I'm gonna
come back to this earth
but I also feel bad if she's [__]
I don't want to be a ghost cuck but I do
feel bad I want to be a ghost cut if
you're still young and you can still
enjoy some some good ass dick yeah but
I'm holding that away from you I mean
like how about this you can have as much
dick as you want but at least have
two or three of my kids I mean she's
still able to get dick right I mean
she's just she didn't make the promise
of not moving on she just yeah she could
like she could she could ask the guy too
that's true wear a condom get my [__] all
over the condom and then what's her
financial situation maybe she's very
resourceful maybe she's financially well
off so the life that she provides for
this child and herself is gonna be no
you know substantial or at least better
than most I disagree with that joke
that's a that's a pretty good plan
though what you said how if she just hid
his sperm and some other guy's condom
yep so she's like oh it's your kid
the doctor who froze the sperm it was
his firm ah because that always happens
doesn't it that always happens a good
switch room light taste test I love
having a taste test oh it's disgusting
right huh I gotta do a taste test God
that's not his calm I know it I know
that's Dr Sanchez is coming there it is
again there it is Dr Sanchez yeah he's
alive and well I don't know man I don't
know wrap it up what are there sad parts
of the story you got first Anthony
um yeah it wasn't his sperm that's yeah
Joe was right we report the news
[Music]
thank you